also at today's hearing nutty jerry
nadler caught again
spreading more conspiracy theories about
the 2020 election actually claiming
the attorney general bill barr and
president trump were fueling more
violence as a campaign strategy
alert take a look you really can't hide
behind legal fictions this time
mr barr it's all out in the open where
the people can see what you are doing
for themselves
the president wants footage for his
campaign ads
and you appear to be serving it up to
him as ordered
in most of these cities the protests had
begun to wind down
before you marched in and confronted the
protesters you did it here in washington
you did it at lafayette square you
expanded to portland
and now you are projecting fear and
violence
nationwide in pursuit of obvious
political objectives
shame on you mr barr shame on you you
liar conspiracy
theorist jerry nadler here with the
reaction fox news contributor former
republican congressman trey gowdy
well the talking points were all the
same uh uh trey
uh i'd call you congressman but it's an
insult at this point after today's shift
show uh
but i'm watching this today they all
regurgitate the same line
you are doing this there is no violence
that's a lie dor you know do do all
these you know
over what 1500 police officers injured
many more
some blinded about oh well now i think
we're up to 16
dead uh is are my eyes deceiving me
trey gowdy well sean if politics is
about contrast we have contrast for
november do
you want the anarchy that you see in
portland and seattle or do you want a
country where
everyone is safe and secure what you
also saw
today is what a serious grown-up
attorney general can do for this country
and it makes me wish and wonder
where we would be if he had been the a.g
from day one
if bill barr had been the president's
first ag and as for jerry
you know crazy uncle jerry now you know
sean while the democrats kept him hidden
in the attic
during impeachment they didn't want him
anywhere near impeachment
and for anybody who wondered why the
chairman of judiciary had
no role in impeachment today you figured
it out
you know something we he actually said
the idea that this is violence in these
cities is a myth
uh claiming you know and then you have
all these
liberal democratic mayors that have
destroyed their cities
both in terms of safety and security
their educational systems are the worst
in the world
and they're out there spreading
conspiracy theories that
a hundred federal agents in most cases
protecting federal property in federal
courthouses
that somehow they're responsible for the
violence for example that has been going
on in portland and seattle forever
six straight weeks almost two months now
in portland
that is not donald trump's fault they
reject his help but he does have an
obligation to protect federal property
and they are doing that job and they are
being injured and blinded as a result
yeah it's his number one obligation the
number one obligation
of government is public safety what i
wish nadler would do
is go find all the the homicide victims
and their family members in new york go
find the parents of that one-year-old
that got killed
and tell them that the violence is
manufactured go find all the homicide
victims in
jerry in your own backyard and tell them
that the violence is manufactured
do you with all we now know in terms of
what is out in the public
about let's see uh hillary clinton's
uh espionage act that i believe 18 usc
793
the fact she deleted subpoenaed emails
bleach bit hammers
uh premeditated fraud on a fisa court
abuse of power corruption
oh by the seventh floor of the fbi
all the names we've often discussed do
you have trey gowdy any doubt
that they abused their power that they
had premeditated fraud on a fisa court
and that they sought to impact an
election and take down a duly elected
president because i have no doubt
and i'm trying to understand why durham
has taken so long at this point
well i have no doubt i would say two
things number one you mentioned horowitz
twice i i
i hope your viewers are wondering why
the chairman of judiciary has never
called michael horowitz as a witness
you know horowitz found misconduct in
law enforcement too
it's called the fbi why has the chairman
of judiciary not called michael horowitz
for the past year and a half but point
number two
we i hope john durham issues his report
and i hope it's fair and fact-centric
but sean we don't need john durham
to know what's on the ballot in november
i don't need john durham to convince me
that the fbi didn't meet any of our
expectations
standards as all the other people with
processed crimes
how do you lie to us in court when you
were told that the evidence is
unverifiable it says at the top of a
fisa warrant verified how do you get
away with that
hope you do not i hope john durham will
prove
that lady justice has blindfolded it
just be patient
justice is slow yes sir
okay i think snails are faster all right
thank you so much